do you know what happens when you buy
stock most people would assume that
their brokerage would go out and get a
stock certificate under their name this
way even if the brokers collapsed those
shares would belong to you but this is
actually not what happens
when you buy a stock from your brokerage
you basically get an iou contract from
the brokerage this contract gives you
certain rights to the stock but not
ownership before you get mad at the
brokerages though you should know that
they don't own the stock either when
they want to buy or sell a stock on
behalf of their clients they have to
send their order to the depository trust
company or the dtc also known as seed co
the dtc will issue the brokerage and iou
statement and this is what gets passed
down to you
so it's actually the dtc that not only
owns your stock but also virtually all
publicly traded shares and securities in
the us and 131 other countries according
to their official website their job is
to bring efficiency to the securities
industry by retaining custody of wait
for it
54.2 trillion dollars
and that was as of july 2017 since then
the u.s stock market has grown 18
trillion dollars and the us has issued
trillions of dollars worth of bonds so
the dtc's total assets are likely well
above 70 trillion dollars today so
here's how seed and co grew to owning
the world
taking a look back the story of dtc
dates back to the 1960s
america had not only recovered from the
great depression but the economy and
more specifically the automotive
industry was booming americans were
making and spending more money than ever
before most of these guys had no
interest in saving or investing either
they themselves or their parents had
lost everything to the great depression
so they felt that it was way better to
just live in the moment this is what
really spawned the terrible but
extremely common trend of living
paycheck to paycheck if your retirement
can be ruined by some irresponsible
financial institution why save in the
first place despite this popular
sentiment given how large and diverse
america is there were naturally some
people who still wanted to invest their
money and given that these guys were
making more money than ever before they
were able to invest more money than ever
before
this resulted in unprecedented trade
volume leading into the 1970s the new
york stock exchange was regularly
processing more than 8 million shares
per day
now compared to today 6 billion shares
per day this was nothing but they didn't
have computers or advanced technology
that could just automatically execute
each trade so they had to manually
handle 8 million shares every single day
and this was basically their limit
so in 1968 the niazi decided to create a
securities clearing firm called the
central certificate service or the ccs
the ccs was basically responsible for
automating the stock market the
president of the nazi at the time robert
hack promised quote we are going to
automate the stock certificate out of
business by substituting a punch card
instead of keeping track of ownership
through stock certificates the ccs kept
all the stock certificates to themselves
and tracked ownership through electronic
records the nyz hoped to reduce the
prevalence of stock certificates by 75
with the ccs but there was one major
issue two-thirds of brokers refused to
use the service
electronic records were extremely
attractive for brokers but they didn't
trust the ccs or computers in general
for that matter so most brokers opted to
continue in their old ways
despite this the ccs continued to expand
their services and attempted to build
credibility in 1970 for instance cscs's
services were extended to the american
stock exchange
around the same time we also saw the
creation of the banking and securities
industry committee or basic
basic give bankers and brokerages a way
to propose rules and standards that the
ccs must follow banks and brokers
deliberated for years about how ccs
should be run but eventually in 1973
basic members agreed to create a beefed
up version of the ccs called the dtc
once a dtc was created more and more
brokerages jumped on board though most
brokerages didn't use the ccs they
wanted to use it they simply didn't want
to explain to their clients that they
will no longer receive stock
certificates because the brokerage is
either too lazy or didn't want to handle
that much paper but as notable banks and
brokerages embraced the dtc smaller
institutions flooded in now that's all
cool and all but how exactly does the
dtc work
well i explained it as an iou contract
at the beginning but it's of course not
that simple whenever a brokerage or bank
agrees to work with the dtc the dtc will
take all of the institutions stock
certificates bond certificates and money
market instruments and enter them into
their database the dtc already owns
billions if not trillions of dollars
worth of each security so they'll mark
down that chase has rights to 10.4
percent of dtc's apple shares and 12 of
their google shares and so on and so
forth as buy and sell orders flow in
during the day the dtc tags up the total
inflow and outflow of each of their
clients for each security the dtc simply
changes the numbers in their database to
reflect the result of the trading day
for example chase's stake in apple might
be reduced to 10.2 percent and their
stake in google might be increased to
12.2 percent but no stock certificates
are actually being swapped and no paper
is being traded the dtc only settles
securities at the end of each day and
each security takes different amount of
times to process based on their time
sensitivity for example options have
expiration dates so they're processed
within one business day stocks on the
other hand take two business days while
slow moving assets like bonds take three
days if you have a cash brokerage
account you're probably well aware of
these settlement times once you sell a
stock you actually have to wait two days
to get your money but with most
brokerage accounts the brokerage will
simply give you the money instantly and
they'll be reimbursed by the dtc over
the next few days so a lot of stock
buyers are completely unaware of
settlement times but that's what's going
on in the background whenever you buy or
sell
buying and selling only accounts for a
small portion of the stock market though
most people simply hold on to their
stocks for years if not decades
so what happens to shares that are
simply held
well the dtc gives their clients a
certain amount of rights to their shares
for example clients will retain voting
rights the right to use the shares as
collateral and a right to buy and sell
options using the underlying stock the
dtc will also process dividend payments
and ensure that each client is paid out
appropriately in essence the dtc
basically takes care of everything i
think it's pretty clear why banks prefer
this over trading billions of stock
certificates per day
all of this still leaves the question is
your brokerage or bank associated with
the dtc
well if you live in the u.s the answer
is yes unless you keep your money in
some obscure offshore bank it's almost a
certainty that your brokerage and bank
work directly with the dtc the dtc does
publicly post all the institutions they
work with so you can go check out that
list if you're interested but the
easiest way to identify affiliation with
the dtc is to simply check if your
brokerage allows for transferring to or
from other brokerages brokerages don't
want to complete transfers manually
especially for customers that are
leaving so if you have the ability to
easily transfer to another brokerage
it's because the brokerage simply
offloads a transferring responsibility
to the dtc also just because your
brokerage is associated with the dtc
doesn't mean that it's impossible for
you to get a stock certificate it is
nearly impossible as brokers just put up
as many roadblocks as they can and i
really don't recommend you try to do
this but if you want the certificate for
novelty purposes or something you can
ask your broker and they're required by
state law to give you your certificate
the process will likely take months
you'll probably be charged hundreds of
dollars and you'll end up spending hours
on the phone with your brokerage but if
you're super persistent you should be
able to get it
this tool is changing fast though it's
just a matter of time until it's
impossible to get a stock certificate in
the uk for example stock certificates
will no longer be a thing starting in
2025. this is really nothing to worry
about as it's simply the far overdue
digitalization of this part of the
industry but as you would guess this has
sparked a lot of conspiracies regarding
the dtc
before we put on our tinfoil hats let's
discuss some legitimate concerns with
seed co
first of all given the sheer volume of
money seed handles it's possible that an
insider steals some of that money
stealing one billion dollars from seed
would be like stealing one dollar from
someone who has 54 thousand dollars
stealing 10 million dollars would be
like stealing just one cent seed only
has 12 directors and half dozen
employees
so theoretically it wouldn't be that
hard for insiders to collude and steal
serious amounts of money
again this is improbable but seeing
cases like bernie madoff it is possible
the second more serious concern is
illegal short selling the process is
super convoluted and technical but in
essence hedge funds were able to
leverage the dtc settlement time and a
borrowing program to engage in naked
short selling which is illegal the
problem can probably be addressed by
some changes in regulation but the
government is too lazy to do anything
about it until it actually leads to some
sort of tangible consequences so in the
meantime the dtc is enabling naked short
selling and finally the third major
concern is that there's very little
transparency from the dtc
given the scale of money that they deal
with all of their activities should be
public knowledge and heavily scrutinized
but only the dtc and their banker
clients have access to dtc's daily
activities making this information
public wouldn't necessarily prevent the
wallet out scheme from taking place but
it would reduce the chances
anyway moving on to the conspiracy some
people believe that seed co is owned by
the billionaires of the world and used
to crash the stock market for their
benefit seed co is a private company and
it's officially owned by its clients but
some believe that these clients are
actually just a handful of powerful
families like the rockefellers and the
rothschilds there seems to be some sort
of unverifiable evidence that these
families have staked in the company but
even if they did it doesn't have to be
nefarious if you were rich you'd
probably deal with the ddc directly as
well instead of going through brokers
another piece of evidence that's used to
propel this conspiracy is that in the
early 1990s jim mcneff who was a
director at the dtc told the media that
the dtc's first control test was four or
five years ago this means that he was
probably referring to black monday and
the stock market crash of 1987. trading
volume is generally the highest during
stock market crashes because investors
are most emotional during this time
periods in 2007 for instance the dtc
sell transactions that were worth 513
trillion dollars so i'm pretty sure jim
was just referring to testing if the dtc
could officially handle that much volume
but conspiracies believe that jim
slipped up and accidentally admitted to
causing the crash
now is the dtc intertwined with a bunch
of hedge funds and market maker
manipulation games i'm sure they are
but do i believe that the dtc is a
conspiracy organization created
specifically to crash and pump markets
no not really
and even if that is the case it's not
like we can do anything about it
so it's probably best to not look too
into it but that's just what i think do
you guys think seed co is involved in
nefarious activities comment that down
below
also drop a like if you've never heard
about this company until now and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one